aH ah AH AHHH FUCKING
whAATTHEFUCK?!
WHAT THE FUCK MAN?!
ooOOOOOHHhh SHIT
eughhhh nononu he's still after me, isn't he?
oh shit oh shit oh shit oh shit oh shiiiiIIIiiiit
aw, fuck!
AH!
oh that was just a--
*monster growling* ohhhh heyyyyy!
hiiiiiiiiiiii!!
ow!!
god damn it!
owwww!
hey you're an assho--
aw fucking shit bag
where's it gonna send me?
what was I supposed to do?
*something went ka-chunk in the night*
oh no...
oh noo.....
NO!
are you KIDDING MEEE!
ARE YOU
fUckING WITH ME?
wHAT THE FU-
Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Leeeeethe!
um, this game was just the
biggest dickhole I have ever seen
anything be... a dickhole
like I cANNOT believe
it would send me back
that far!
like, unbelievably that far!
so I just wanted to say that
so you know why I'm back here but we're gonna
fast forward (obviously) to the place where I just was
so that you won't lose too much progress
it'll be fine
whatever
man, and I luh- I didn't
I didn't get all the notes that I had
there were a bunch of crap around here that I was su-
so, I'll be back, I'm getting back to the place
but I'm just pissed off
and, uh, it's fuckin bullshit.
ya know, it's-it's fuckin bullshit
wow
that took a while to get back here!
*sighing* huhhh
pretty douchey!
pretty douchey.
cannot lie, pretty douchey
preeetty damn douchey
you don't see me do ya?
I got the barrel of disguiiiisee!
it's the barrel of invisibility
you'll never find me
*deep laughing* ooOOwwAHHahaha
*softly* fuckin douchebag
do not!
what are you doing?
go aWAY!
he went away last time, what is this bullshit?
*thuclank*
(BearTrap #1 triggers)
Ow, Fucking- It got me after it didn't get me, It finally got me, fuck you.
Fuuuuuuuuuuck yoooooooouuuu.
OK!
So we're officially back, this is good, Yay! we're back.
OK, so I know what I need to do
And
Ah, god dam it, I passed by it again, why is so easy to pass by?
SO, this is a loop, this is a loop with these vents. So what I need to do is -
I need to get a yellow thing from beyond THAT way where the guy is guarding
put it here so that i can grab it through THERE, that's why that gap is there.
and that's the thing that I need the be able to move on.
But, to get that, I got to get it from over here which means that I gotta get by HIM
so if he runs after me, which I got a feeling he's gunna
Because he's an asshole like that
*Foot steps*
Oh, i thought that was a noise
Can't see x1
Can't see x2
Can't see x3
Oh shit, its soo dark
OK, so he is not gunnin' for me
like-like he did last time
Which is weired
But
its also good because here are my batches of things that i need,
*inhale*
and i just need them out of there, and then take it with me
shit
I got to be able to-
there we go
Ahh!!!
Got it, Ok. SO i got this
What does this do?
*Clunck*
Ohhh!!!
Handy that.
So that's probably a way, back, Yeah ok, I know where this is.
*thunk*
Oh shit
Just gotta be careful.
If he's lurking arround
I might have to bail and run.
*eerie noises*
K, looks like  he's skidadled,
So, all I gotta do is- I can actually, I drop this over on the other side, crawl through, and then i should be good.
*Item crashes to the ground*
Okay.
So it looks like he's leaving me alone. Then why did he kill me last time?!
What did I do?!
Did I Smell bad?!
(Probably)
Was I offensive in some way?!
I don't know.!
Man! I cannot believe that they didn't put in like a checkpoint system in-between that
because if that there going to put a monster, like there's  every chance, especially if the monster is actually lethal
*Machine hisses*
There's every chance that I could die
*Wheel creeks*
Er, the player could die and like having to go all the way back,
That's ridiculously far back to go on.
So, anyway
Besides the point.
OK, so half.
*Pipes hiss*
Thats not half.
*Wheel creaks*
How about half?
No?
K, so i gotta hit it
K, go go go go go
Annnd a boop
*Click click click click*
Boopidy boop boop boop boop boop boop boop boopidy boop boop boop
No?
*Clunck clunk*
*Creak*
*Clunck*
Okay?!
What am I missing?!
*Wheel creaks*
*Click click click click*
No?
God damn it.
Ohhhhhhh!
*Wheel creaks*
God damn it
OK, so-
Uhhhh, I knew it was something, God dam it im such an idiot. This has individual controls on this...
pipe here, err, like
*Wheel creaks*
here's the confusing thing.
This is why its confusing.
Because...
If you hit it once it will go all the way.
But if you hit it again
It'l stop and I did no know that, I was opperating on the assumption it was an all or nothing thing, OK, and then
Its at half
We hit the button and then it opens.
OK, so I'm an idiot and that took me way longer then it should have but thankfully you guys
wouldn't of wasted your time with seeing all that
You guys just saw us get to the end, so hurayyy.
Man I can not believe how long that took, I had to play through all of that again
I'm still a little pissed about it
Why am I back here?
Why am I back here?!
Did I open something?
Did I fix something?
I was just back here, because, it was... being a bitch
*Doors Opens*
Is it work-Ohhhh its working, great, cool.
Fina-whoa
Cut scene huh?
Uh oh
*Quick, light, running footsteps from behind*
*Gets stabbed*
Hey! Ow, my gullet.
Ah! All my blood
Um?
Well, that was tantalizing once again, right up at the exit.
Why do you keep doing that?
Onscreen text: I wonder what kind of horrid experiment took place here?
My mother...
Could she still alive somewhere on this island?
I doubt it after all that I have seen
This all feels strangely familiar.
Why am I being chased? Who are they?
I bet they carry the many secrets I seek. If only insanity had not claimed them first.
Mark: Yeah and if only you hadn't been knocked out,
had something penetrating your gullet and then dying.
Hello, are you the good doctor?
HI
OK?
It's wonderful that you're excellent at sousaphone.
Wow, *giggles*  That didnt com out right. I'm sorry about that.
*Sniffles*
It's wonderful that you're excellent at the sousaphone
Which is what i wanted to say and would of been funny  in context which now im explaining it too much and its just not funny.
Okay.
Well.
Oh good, my shit bukkit is here
Pre-filled
Most excellent. Thank you sir.
*softly* alright.
Reads note: So intent she was on cutting of the child's limbs that she didn't notice that she didn't notice that her victim was long dead.
She pierced what was remand of the body with the blade had crudely attached to her wrist replacing what was once her soft and caring hand.
The dirty sac on her head covered her face but could not mask her anger. What a sight she was to behold standing among her young victims, her torn cloths drenched in blood.
Their soft skulls cracking open under her boots as she walked towards me, a sound well known to us both.
A real monster! Yet, she is better off a monster than a coward like me
Its been 32 years since that faithful event and I havn't left her side ever since.
Mark: Whaaaattt???
This sounds like a love letter towards the end there.
wooo boy.
wooo nelly.
Something weird is going off here
Also I remember a scene in amnesia where i was in a prison
Is there a brick in the wall i need to pull?
With my psychic powers?
Eh bluh
*clunk*
Bet you weren't counting on that douche nosils
Easy peazy lemon squeeze me
*quietly* All right, what else we got?
*Chomp*
Food.
Whatever the hell this is? Beef jerky?
Page: My precious room is gone,  it had been taken from me. I knew every single stone by name and now my beloved friends are gone.
Today will be once again the first. Is this another test I wonder? I suspect the guards know but they never speak. Their footsteps tell their stories but I need more practice. They haven't noticed yet but I have.
Something feels different in this cell. We have been transferred no doubt but there's something else too.
Mark: Okay, that's confusing.
I'm not 100% sure on what you're talking about, but
I glugged down some blue goo and hopefully that's going to help me on my, journey.
Man, they should of posted the guard to me unless there is only a few of them left.
Which there might very well be.
Ehh
Whoever was coming up behind me by the way was very stip stepy
Veeeeeeery quick.
*Clunk*
Okay?
*Door creaks*
Hello?
God it's so dark.
Everything just seems to be open around here.
Hep
I said, Hep
There we go.
Oh.
What did that do?
sounded like it just locked me in.
Why'd it do that?
It did!
It did lock me in.
What was the point in that?
Oh ok.
Hello?
Ah
ooh
So pitch black
Eh
*Flies buzzing around*
Ehg
*creak*
*Thud*
Page: The smell of burning incense made my blood run cold
I could hear two or three men laughing and cursing. I worried less about the first two but Jacob?
I had seen him hunting prey, ripping of limbs with his his hands as if he was drawing pleasure from it
I walked around the house following the sound of  their footsteps.
Peeking over the edge of the kitchen window, I thought that maybe I could trick them somehow, perhaps make some noise and lead them to the front door so she could jump through the window and escape.
But I was too late.
Mark: OK, I'm very confused .
1. Why are these notes here?
2.What are you talking about?
Sounds like a family home but from what I'm able to tell its just been a mine-shaft.
I mean everything has gone horrible wrong here, don't get me wrong.
But.
Eeeh
*Clunk*
Damn it.
Stop
*Clunk*
No?
What was the point in pulling all of that off?
Oh shit.
Whoops.
*Clunck*
No?
*Thud*
Uh, well no point on keep trying.
Eh
*Thud*
No?
*Blocked doorway breaks*
Bam!
Ooooh That did work.
Man, that was actually kinda hard to do.
Ehhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh
Aaaahhhhhh
Break you bitch.
Oh, it didn't break.
EH
Eh, oh, fucking crock
There
Okay, now that we got that. This isn't openable. Now we go down here. OK. Into the pit of doom I say, splish splash.
Oh boy.
That's not what i wanted.
Oh
Oh shit
*Splash*
Oh, hello. That was a very excitable jump
Okay
*Eerie noises*
Don't seem good.
Wherever the hell I am.
Nothing over there.
*Splash*
Huuuh
Okay
eeeeeeeeeeh. OK
Allrighty then
Hello
*Jammed lever*
Hey
Oh, that ones stuck.
stuck
Page: We have been cast into eternal darkness for it is our fate to carry this burden.
Shadows grow in our finite minds haunted by our guilt and yet we chant with heavy breths
The fabric of life being stretched out far and wide from this place
The weeping of its threads piercing my ears before it breaks into a thousand stars.
Is this a mockery of the gods?
Mark: Are you trying to be poetic?
Cause it wasn't very good. It was confusing.
What are these?
Are they balls?
Can I light them on fire?
Look like it.
Can I li- no OK never mind then.
That would be too interesting.
OK so what was I supposed to do down here?
Was I supposed to do anything or  was this another place with a mysterious note in it?
Dam it. It was just another place with a mysterious note and a stick, stupid son of a bitch.
How am I supposed to be able to do this?
Hep
Beh
Ah. No?
OK so what, do I need some oil to do that?
How about this?
Ehhh
No?
Shiiiiiit
Ok
That didn't work and I can't open it so.
There's gotta be something else or some way to get that luuuuubed up
If I know anything about horror games, they sure love to use their lube
Oh, never mind. I just come over here into the new area where there's obviously new things
Hello.
Hi
Page: She sat on her favorite chair as the men kept twisting her arm,  almost as if he was enjoying her screams, and then looked like he wanted more.
Jacob pushed her head firmly down onto the table and ordered the third man to pull out the last box of incense
I couldn't really tell if they used it for their ritual or mask their own stench
He grabbed her hair and pulled her head back and said almost whispering "Its time".
I could see that she tried hard to hold it but the awful smell was the final drop. Nausea took over her body and fluid sprung out of her mouth and nose.
With each cough she struggled for air, then finally he violently smashed her face into the table twice.
No human beings should be capable of committing such an atrocious act, yet that was what I had witnesed
Another worldly scream escaped her crimson lips whilst he was holding the back of her neck like a captured animal.
Mark: Fuck man, cr-oh my god that's horrifying.
Why?
Eh why, seriously?
None of this makes sense. Why are there rampaging bands of horrible monsters and killing people in the countryside,
And why are people writing about it down here, where am I, this is supposed to be a mine-shaft, it looks like a - a freakin' castle dungeon.
Who built this?!
Like it seem like they were doing scientific studies here but it all seems just like, medival architecture, who built-
Oh god, hello.
Ehhhh
*Flies buzzing*
Why do the flies sound like moaning?
Who built this?!
OK, moving on up
Elhh
*Thud*
Besides, who witness that?
Page: Dammed rodents they keep coming back, however many traps i place
Something draws them to this place I wonder what it could be...
Mark: Uhhh, maybe all the dead bodies.
Oh, so you're Beartrap man
Fuuuuuuck yuuuuuuuoooo
*sound of box being pushed*
Was there any point to this?
Was there any reason to this?
There must of been a reason for this.
*barrel crashes to the ground*
Hello I see you.
Habooskie
Oooh
Hey wey, whoa, whoa, whoa,
Where you going?
Did you fall down?
Yes you did somehow.
Gimme you
Oh
Oh no, I thought that there's something over here
Man this is just bizarre.
Ok so what am I supposed to do, am i supposed to light something on fire?
Bur this brush?
*Chair sizzles*
Ahhhh, I am
Habooskie
Yeah!! I'm smart
I'm smart
Look at me, I'm smart
I always love it when I actually get something, because I so don't often do
*Fire sizzles*
Eh, it's taking a little while to burn, come on, hurry up already
I ain't got all day
Burn down.
Burn the whole fucker down.
Burn this whole castle down , whatever the hell it is?
Its obviously not-
Normal
It just-fuck, fuck you
Oh!
Well, did that work or was it just time? I have no idea which.
Well shit.
I guess i gotta walk across hot embers.
You get out of here.
*Box flies to the side*
OK, here we go- Owie!! Ouchkabibles!
OK, I probably should of waited till that cooled but I didnt have time.
*Drinks blue goop*
Dookay, got the lawtham,
Bleeeh
Eeh
OK
Where am i now?
Jezums
So many places to go
OH!
Oh, okay.
I suppose we've entered the fire portion of the game.
OK. why and how and what am I supposed to do here?
Oh, there's a checkpoint in there, good god that better actually save for me
Because if it hasn't saved yet, I will be soo pissed.
I'ma get to that and then I'maa end the episode here.
Cause, I've been playing this particular one for way too long trying to get to where I was supposed to be.
Whats the point of this?
OK
So far so goo
Aha
*Beartrap #2*
Fucking god dam it with your fucking- how was I supposed to know?!
*Beartrap #3*
FUCK OFF!!!
Do not kill me.
If you kill me with this bullshit.
I sware.
*Beartrap #4*
UHHHHHHHHH!!!!!!!!!!
Where? I looked.
There was nothing.
Good god.
*Grabs planks off the doorway*
Better not be more.
Those take a huge chunk of my health.
Huge chunk
Page: He gave us ink and paper to record his work, how kind of him.
I keep smiling every day to show my devotion. That's all he desired from us but no one understood.
I knew all along! In the end he only wanted us cured.
So, you're probably all talking about Dr. Burninham
Bringinham
Brugenstine
I cant remember
Ehh
*Crash*
OW!!!
This better of gotten me to that god dam checkpoint.
Where the fuck did it drop me?
Where the fric did it drop me?
We-were is this?
Where am I now?
I don't hear the buzz.
*Clunk*
Uuuhh, man, I probably got turned around again.
Maybe back over this way.
Thought I was going to drop me onto the thing.
OH my god!!
I'm back at the beginning.
What the fuck?!
But was this open?
*Thunk*
I'm back at the beginning but what-
Wu- how did I get back here?
I didn't want to get back here.
Oh god dam it, okay.
Trap? Uh, no.
*Smash*
*Glug*
Oh, ok
*Beartrap #6*
Fuuuuuuuuck, man, stop it!!!
Stop it with that, you're such a dick.
Oh, there's nothing over here
*Clunk*
Why did I come back?!
There's no reason to come back. Is there another one?
I fucking sware.
*Running*
I fucking sware
All right.
So far so goo but why did I-Uhh man I didn't wanna drop down
If I'd known it was gunna come back here I wouldn't of dropped down.
Dam it, god dam it
*Clunk*
OK, that opened that
What could that do?
How about this?
Ehh
*Clunk*
Okay
That helps, maybe.
Locked
This seems like a way out over there.
This is definetly a medival castle
*Monster roars*
Fuck, wait, Front? Back? OH SHIT
Oh, I'm out of stamina?!
No. do not kill me now
Do not!
No not!!
I'm out of stamina.
You fucking ashole
If you-If you fucking kill me.
I sware
Ohhhh you bitch
Oh you bitch
*Clunck*
Oh if you kill me
If you kill me
I will never, ever forgive you
Game!
*Hi*
Is there a way to open this god dam gate?
Fuck you
Fuck you soo hard game
You son of a bitch
*Monster roars to the sound of the gate opening*
OK.
What was that?
OH good.
Oh good
OH GOOD
Oh Go-Oh good
Oh fuck
Oh good
AH! no not that way.
*Breartrap #7*
I saw the trap, I saw it
*Beartrap #8 triggers*
AHH!!!
*Floor crumbles*
OH NOO!!!!!!
*Dead*
Okay
*Markimoo_lookaround.exe has started*
*Markimoo_lookaround.exe has stoped*
*starting Markimoo_shocked.exe*
DID I DIE?!?!?!
*Markimoo.exe has stoped*
*Markimoo.exe started*
*resuming*
*Items crash to the floor*
OH WHAT!!!
ARE YOU FUCKING KIDDING ME, GOOD GOD!!!
WHY DID I DIE?!?!?!?!
WHAT WAS I SUPPOSED TO DO?!?!?!
I WHENT THE WAY I WAS GUIDED.
AND I'M PUNISHED BY GOING BACK
FUCKING
God dam it, what the fuck!!!
*Sighs*
All right, I guess we're done with this episode but holy shit.
Are you kidding me, what was i supposed to do?
Was I NOT supposed to go towards freedom because "oh no, that's punish worthy"
God dam it.
Okay, i dont want to be pissed at this game but thats just bad gameplay
Alright
Anyway, im going to end this episode before i start rambling about how pissed I am, but maybe I should of made a better choice but,
It seemed like the only obvious one, it was like, "Run bitch" and i ran
So, either way,
Thank you everybody for watching so much for watching
As always, I will see YOU in the next video
BUH BYE
Top video: Oh scuse me im not- im not doing this on purpose
Im legit-wow I'm legitimately trying here
Bottom video: Report back to who, what n' why?!
Wait, what happened.
What was that button for?
FIN
Closed captions provide by By Gizmotech13. I hope you all have a lovely day/ night :) (also looked over by one person but giz did all the work, thanks giz!)